Marsha said that she was who she was and
her motto was I me I'm here and you all
better get your life a lot of people
that come in and Vassy I'd say that the
pieces are like a child could draw that
and they're not painted by someone who
departed but he's like an extremely
talented painter
although the John looks simple they were
extremely complex they usually talked
about social issues social commentary
they dealt with things such as racism
economic equality and all these things
in the nation as an artist he's
influenced me because he was someone
that was very brash his look was very
uncaring but it was home and that's
something that's been important to me
especially going out my hair I saw him
as someone who was extremely comfortable
and who he was and the way that he
looked exactly how he wanted to look
Mike Wallace was if that's how society
thought that a black man's hair should
be at that time or how you see wearing
his clothes look at the photo while
trying to do it was really hard and then
to see the finished product was like oh
I accomplished it it was really cool to
see they look like who I look up to it
was really good feeling
[Music]
there was like the civil rights movement
and then Malcolm X and I think a lot of
people misinterpreted him a lot of
people could like consider him to be the
one who was like no there needs to be
violence when actually he was the one
thing like no there needs to be peaceful
protesting the black people also need to
learn how to defend themselves and he
was just very realistic very
unapologetic you know with segregation
when segregation was happening he was
also very much like no okay so like this
is happening but we need to also have
like black organizations we need to like
you know organized black people together
and like if they want segregation and
we're gonna give it to them and prove to
them that black people can still
flourish throughout this time just
because the system is against you
doesn't mean that you have to be against
yourself and you can still fight and you
can still make it
that's important because these issues
that were happening in the sixties and
seventies are still happening today like
you know I mean yes we have made a lot
of progress but there's still a huge
fight that needs to happen I was almost
moved to tears which was really
surprising I didn't expect to be so
moved to see myself with like a
side-by-side picture of him and kind of
look like him it surprised me I actually
did really well since ballin was a
writer poet he specialized in thinking
and writing the chinking on black
culture of the black experience I think
is important for the world and not just
Americans even like the entire world
because they need to know that like
black people are people of color and
people artists are here in existing and
have something to say and our value it
makes me feel ok that I walk away for
something that feels like a good deal it
feels like a good job if I'm unhappy
with it he talks about the good deal of
a good job at this warm house and yet
you can't get inside of it and you don't
want to be inside of it and if you get
inside of it you got to 5-minutes
because you just have to be working on
your own thing it's great to talk and
take butters and blue baldwin I think he
was important to the black community to
know that it's been done before and that
she can do it again
during a time when women were like
girding they're like loins and like
hiding their bodies she was celebrating
her body dancing topless and had over a
thousand marriage proposals and growing
up and hearing about Josephine Baker and
how in control of her sexuality she was
it was definitely something I looked to
when I became a woman during the World
War two Josephine Baker worked with the
French to carry secrets in her sheet
music and was awarded like multiple
French medals of honor afterwards she
came back to the United States during
the Civil Rights Movement was the only
woman to speak during the 1963 march on
Washington not only was she a celebrity
but she parlayed her celebrities into
major activism and used her power to the
betterment of other people
so Marsha P Johnson was a fierce
activist and advocate from the late 60s
and early 70s let me paint you a picture
it's 1969 you're black you're a woman
and you're a member of the queer
community he realized that equality was
for everyone despite your sexuality your
orientation or your race and she was a
part of the major movement and the
Stonewall Riots in 1969 and the
unfortunate part is after all the work
that her and Sylvia Rivera did for the
gay movement they actually shunned her
and they despised her because she didn't
fit into a certain class Stonewall was a
huge part of the movement because they
weren't afraid it was one of the few
times in history where queer trans gay
lesbian people stood together unified
and said that they would no longer take
it and that they had a right to hold
space it feels good to know that the
reason why I'm here today is because of
people like Marsha P Johnson and the
work that she's done so I feel I'm a
descendent of greatness it's extremely
important for black children to see
black heroes in the field because if you
want to believe that you can achieve
success you want to believe that someone
that looks like you had went through the
same things who you had the same
struggles as you and understands where
you're coming from and a lot of times
you just want to be happy to know that
you can do it